but I've noticed this trends of average
women getting exceptional outcomes not
only in the media
um and partially partially I do think
this is whole flation because again you
know 100 years ago pretty much all the
guys got a virgin so by you know 2023 if
you're not a virgin you would have been
a haul 100 years ago I I don't make the
rules right I know that's not the same
definition in modern times but if we're
gonna go from a historical point of view
it is very unusual to be in a time
period where the women are not virgins
again like I do think that men have to
work 10 times harder for a chick that's
a lot more average than their
grandfathers and their
great-grandfathers would have gotten